though and I were fortunate enough to
work with Hal Ashby so I'm total master
yeah we we booked I did his first I did
his live looking at his career like what
a great I think one of the greatest in
American directors have owned Hal he was
God he had such art cojones you know he
would you know we would have the script
for how was just a and kind of an
outline you know he wasn't locked in
stone at all and how can I talk about
this is such a weird experience well let
me I'm kind of on a roll now whether I
gotta finish it off this is a movie
called eight million ways to die and I
remember when how came to me with this
project said I want to make this project
it really didn't seem like a Hal Ashby
project the script I read and I asked
how why he wanted to make it it was
about a cop an alcoholic cop and Hal
said well you know that's a really good
question I guess that's why I want to
make it I want to find out why I want to
make it but he was drawn to it you know
and he says it's not going to be
anything like this script it's going to
be more into the substance abuse and
that kind of thing so we went for it it
turned out the producer of the movie
really had no faith in house approach
and I can imagine from the finance Sears
point of view how frightening it would
be because you'd see the day lesion of
the stuff you see from the day before
and it's nothing like the script you say
well why don't you know what is this guy
doing and so this producer had had a spy
on the set put on this put a spy in this
set and Hal just beautifully you know
loved the guy you know got the guy in on
our team and it turns out the guy was an
alcoholic and he was my technical
advisor on the show he became hell you
know we would and we would you know I
would go up to hell
a large scene about you know having to
stand up at a meeting and give a speech
and there was nothing written and I
would go to hell I said yeah well what
are we gonna do for this he's aw you'll
figure it out you know go talk to Bobby
yeah and so I go over there and more we
got him working on the thing the more he
fell apart of it and he became our ally
and but we would just do total improv
like that with Howe and then the sad
thing is one of the saddest experiences
I've had making movies how who is of
course an award-winning editor you know
he he gave it to his editor to assemble
and took off for a week and in that week
the producer came and kidnapped the film
fired Hal and proceeded to cut the film
just totally against the grain and it
was such a heartbreaking you know thing
and I'm you know you know just destroyed
how he was such a cool cat man how I
remember he said he was Andy Garcia's
first movie and we just had a wonderful
time on it and he said to both both Andy
myself he said you know when this is
over I'm going to get a little bungalow
in Malibu I'm going to set up an editing
Bay there and I'm going to invite you
guys over to edit your scenes because I
think you'll come up with some good
ideas you know